I am talking about the extent to which
uh gains in in muscle mass and strength
differ between individuals and just uh
Fitness in general increases in Fitness
level I'm going to talk about uh
variability in gains and aerobic fitness
as well
um but yeah like I wanted to talk about
this because
I think people
often severely underestimate uh the
extent to which just gains in muscle
strength general fitness levels
following a training program differ
between people
um
and I think that there are some negative
outcomes of that one is I think that uh
folks who maybe respond to training
worse than average uh but not to any
sort of like concerning or or crazy
degree you know like they're they're
they maybe have like a 30th percentile
uh type response to resistance training
which is a completely normal response uh
they look at say averages or people
showing up on their social media feed
who typically are going to be above
average that's why
folks find them interesting and
therefore the algorithm is promoting
them to you and they think oh no like
I'm doing something terribly wrong
um and you know what I'm experiencing is
very atypical but it's not like 30th
percentile like that's
that's not out of the ordinary at all
um so yeah like to hopefully give some
of those folks peace of mind and also
just to uh kind of help people get
grounded uh for for being able to better
evaluate things they see in their own
training uh gains their training
Partners make uh stuff they see on
social media Etc so just just basically
to to put people on firmer footing to
better understand the sorts of
variability you should expect to see in
training responses uh and then also
towards the end of this segment I'm
going to talk about if you are someone
who responds to training worse than the
typical person like you know I would
anticipate that this probably applies to
about 50 percent of folks in the
audience give or take
um some some things that you can
potentially do about that to uh
either make better gains or to maybe
find a bit more contentment in the gains
that you do see cool yeah so
um
first off to start with the thing that
the the thing that kind of got me
thinking that I should make this segment
is in the stronger by science subreddit
uh when we were on summer break uh there
was a thread someone posted that that
was basically asking about this General
topic
um saying that they had gone back
through the podcast archives and they uh
had seen some content around uh around
this General subject floating around in
The Ether and they were like ah but it's
a shame Greg and Eric have never
discussed this in depth uh but I had
um so there's an article on Stronger by
science that was published I think in
2015 2016 on this precise subject uh but
that was before the podcast existed and
at this point more people listen to the
podcast than than read articles on the
site which is totally fine uh so it
hadn't occurred to me that a pretty good
chunk of our audience probably hadn't
come in contact with this information so
part of this segment is just going to be
restating some of the content from that
article but it will take it a step
further and a step deeper but the the
stronger by science article on this
topic will be linked in the show notes
so just to start with just to give you
uh a general idea of the extent to which
uh hypertrophy following a resistance
training program can differ between
people I'm gonna start by just briefly
talking about a study by Bauman and
colleagues from 2007 uh in all of the
sources that I reference will be linked
in the show notes if you want to check
them out title of this paper was cluster
analysis tests the importance of
myogenic gene expression during myofiber
hypertrophy in humans so in this study
there were 66 subjects they all went
through a 16-week training program
training their quads three times per
week
um and afterwards the authors or the the
researchers did a cluster analysis where
they basically looked to see uh like the
the split out the people who basically
had like 25th to 75th percentile type
gains the people in the bottom uh
quartile and the people in the top
quartile looking at uh gains in fiber
cross-sectional area just to see how you
know results differed between
individuals and so in this study after
everyone went through the exact same
training program for 16 weeks uh the
bottom quartile of responses on average
these people their their quad fibers did
not increase in cross-sectional area uh
at all on average like the the mean
change was Zero Square micrometers uh
for the uh who they termed modest
responders kind of the the middle 50th
percentile so from 25th to 75th
percentile uh the average increase in
fiber cross-sectional area for the
vastus lateralis was like a thousand
square micrometers and for who they
termed the extreme responders who I
really wouldn't call Extreme responders
we're talking about people from the 75th
to 100th percentile so 75th percentile
that's that's nothing extreme
um but yeah who they termed the extreme
responders the increase in fiber
cross-sectional area was a little bit
over 2 000 Square micrometers so just
going from essentially the median to
kind of what the top 20 25 percentiles
see that's like a two-fold difference in
gains uh and the person who experienced
the most uh hypertrophy in this study uh
it was like 32 3300 Square micrometers
so there the gains that that individual
saw were like three three and a half
times better than average so that's you
know just to just to kind of get your
feet wet on the the sort of variability
we tend to see and if you're if you're
watching on YouTube uh you can look at
the screen uh a figure from the study
will be there looking for or looking at
you this is really convenient the way
that the numbers uh kind of cluster
around numbers because it's like the the
lower beloved numbers cluster around
numbers well yeah that was a eloquent
way of saying it but let me uh try to
explain that more so like the the
approximate average for the lower
Response Group was like zero yeah and
then there were nice round numbers so
like the middle responder groups it was
like a thousand so it's like zero
hypertrophy units or one and then up
around two thousand you know a nice
doubling is where you get the kind of
high response groups and then up around
3 000 like a tripling of the average
approximately yeah is where you get the
like basically like the the real outlier
right like the the person that you see
on Instagram and you're like there's no
way they're Natty right well and I mean
I would even push back against that
because this study had 16 subjects like
yeah that's not the sort of sample you'd
need to find true outliers well yeah
yeah like that within this sample yeah
that's someone with like one out of 60 6
type response not one in a million yeah
you know yeah uh so yeah another I think
probably even better study that looked
at this uh classic paper by huble and
colleagues from 2005 title is
variability and muscle size and strength
gain after unilateral resistance
training the reason this is a
particularly good uh study is because it
is a particularly huge study so it was
585 subjects all going through the same
biceps training intervention over three
months and again if you're watching on
YouTube you can see the hypertrophy
results now the the typical change in
biceps cross-sectional area was like 15
20 for both the male and female subjects
but the people who had the worst
response to the training uh actually
experienced a small decrease in biceps
cross-sectional area uh and these were
completely untrained folks so you know
you should expect most people to
experience at least some hypertrophy but
the people with the very very worst
responses actually saw small decreases
and then the people with the very very
best responses experienced increases in
biceps cross-sectional area in excess of
55 percent so you know we're talking
about untrained folks going to the gym
for the first time training for three
months and their biceps getting 50
percent larger
and as you pointed out with the prior
study like the best response was about
three times the average response and
that's more or less what we see here
like the average response was gains of
15 20 percent the best responses were
like 50 60 so about three times better
than average uh and then also the study
assessed changes in maximum voluntary
contraction strength of the biceps or
just elbow flexion mvcs and you see a
pretty normal distribution here as well
with most people experiencing gains in
elbow flexion strength of around 20
percent so so that was approximately the
average with a handful of people
experiencing small decreases a handful
of people experiencing increases in the
70 to 90 percent range and one subject
experiencing an increase of 145 percent
which I'll note I don't take that
completely at face value I kind of think
they probably just had a bad pre-test
number like just not a great test uh
because that's that's a pretty extreme
outlier but in terms of just the general
variability we see very similar to
hypertrophy yeah
and it is tough with with uh MVC uh you
know with an isometric test like this
um because I think some people say well
what do you mean a bad Baseline test you
know but it can be difficult especially
with untrained folks like it's pretty
easy with a bench press because it's
like well you're going to unrack the bar
and it's either gonna pin you to the
bench or it isn't right but with an MVC
test it's like okay push as hard as you
can against this pad and by the way you
never do leg extensions but push against
this as a leg extension as hard as you
possibly can and then you just have to
say like
was that did you do your best and
they're like yeah and you're like are
you are you certain though and like you
can have some some things in place to
try to uh alleviate the shortcomings of
that to the best of your ability but
sometimes you do just get a crappy
Baseline test Oh yeah and when you're
assessing 585 subjects the odds of
having one bad test in there is around a
hundred percent right yeah yeah uh so
yeah so that's talking about hypertrophy
and strength to this point uh like I
said I I'm gonna touch on aerobic
fitness as well
um so a classic study the Heritage study
uh from I think it started in in maybe
the late 80s uh through the 90s and this
uh the Heritage study itself is really
cool if if you're someone who's
interested in uh aerobic training in
general heritability of uh trainability
and and general fitness characteristics
the Heritage study was a huge trial
absolute classic definitely worth
looking into
um but the particular paper resulting
from that study that I'm going to talk
about here title was familial
aggregation of VO2 max response to
exercise training colon results from the
Heritage study from Bouchard and
colleagues in 1999
and this study very similar to the Hue
ball study big sample size 481 total
subjects previously sedentary
um and they completed 20 weeks of a
standardized aerobic training program on
a cycle ergometer twice per week and the
researchers assessed absolute VO2 max
before and after training so not MLS per
kg per minute but just total MLS per
minute
um
and the the typical gains in this study
were around 400 MLS uh uh gain in VO2
max but we see the same sort of normal
distribution here as well with the
people again previously sedentary
subjects uh people who when you put them
on an aerobic training program you
should expect to see gains in aerobic
fitness the people with the absolute
worst responses actually experience
small decreases in aerobic fitness and
the people who had the absolute best
responses increase their absolute VO2
max by more than a liter per minute so
about two and a half times uh as large
of gains as the average so similar types
of variability as we see with
hypertrophy and strength
um which is to say very very substantial
variability and then finally to address
gains in hypertrophy in a pretty
systematic way
um I happen to have a little bit of
information on hand from the barbalia
investigation we did a couple years ago
the details of that aren't worth getting
into here that would be a huge diversion
huge rabbit hole look at us practicing
restraint yeah a new thing for the
podcast uh by the way you did a really
good job editing the last episode oh
thank you uh for the listeners I got
very sidetracked on some dumb [ __ ]
during Eric's segment uh and I felt very
bad about it but hopefully you didn't
notice because Eric is the magic of
editing yes
anyway so if you're interested in uh
learning more about statistics and how
one might go about
uh looking into
sketchy looking research maybe check out
the article it'll be linked in the show
notes uh but one of the things that that
we were interested in in that
investigation was what is the typical
variability we see in strength gains
after uh a resistance training program
the reason we were interested in this is
the studies by barbalia and colleagues
reported uh very very low variability
and strength gains like you know if a
training program added 20 kilos to
people's squats on average they might
report like 20 plus or minus two kilos
like basically everyone gained between
15 and 25 kilos without much variability
which seemed pretty low so uh we had an
archive of like 83 studies that that I
had uh looked into for just like various
meta-analysis projects previously so it
was an unbiased sample that we weren't
just cherry picking for the purposes of
this particular investigation
where we could basically look and see
like hey in in the literature as a whole
in a pretty large group of studies what
is the typical variability we see in
strength gains and that was Quantified
in terms of what's called a Cohen's DZ
value
um which all that is is average gains in
a particular strength measure divided by
the standard deviation for the gains so
for example if in a study people put 20
plus or minus 10 kilos on their bench
press That's mean of 20 divided by
standard deviation of 10 that's a
Cohen's DZ value of 2. so the typical
Cohen's DZ value we saw kind of the
weighted average from this whole sample
of studies was about 1.6
uh and so just to put that in context uh
a Cohen's bz value of 1.6 means that if
there's a training intervention where
the typical gain or the average gain in
strength is 20 kilos that means within
one standard deviation you're looking at
uh on the low end a gain of 7.5 kilos
and on the top end a gain of 32 and a
half kilos so we're we're certainly not
talking about outliers here just within
one standard deviation of the mean
you're looking at a a difference in
strength gains of more than four-fold so
you know a an increase of 32 and a half
kilos is more than four times greater
than seven and a half kilos so that's
again just within a single standard
deviation within two standard deviations
you're looking at on the low end a
decrease of 5 kilos up to an increase of
45 kilos and so that's that's normal
[ __ ] again again we're not talking about
outliers here we're talking from the
2.5th percentile up to the 97.5
percentile uh so that's kind of where
most normal responses would fall so you
know uh that's I think of that though
think of the the number of people who if
it's like you and your training partner
hypothetically you're both pretty
similar at Baseline you both do the same
program together one person gains 42
kilograms the other person loses three
and it's like yeah that that checks out
yeah like those those seem like extreme
responses but we're again we're staying
within two standard deviations of the
mean here like that's that's just
perfectly normal stuff that you would
observe all the time uh and then just in
terms of not so much gains and strength
gains and muscle gains and aerobic
fitness but just kind of like real world
data on how strong people actually are
so back back in 2015 I sent out a survey
to the stronger by science audience
um asking you know basically hey if
you're training pretty hard for either
powerlifting specifically or like power
lifting style training fill out this
survey uh there were a lot of things in
the survey but one of the things I asked
about or two of the things I asked about
were how long have you been training and
what is your one rep max Squad binge and
deadlift
um
and I I want to talk about this just
variability in terms of how strong
people actually are
relative to how long they've been
training because I think that there's
[Music]
um
unfortunate facet of the strength
training content landscape is the
concept of strength standards tables
um which I think
outside of competitive environments are
virtually worthless like if you are
actually competing in powerlifting and
you might want to know if you're like a
class three lifter or a Master Level
lifter or whatever like you can look at
those tables and see how you stack up
because there's a purpose there like
that's that's saying how relatively
competitive are you compared to your
peers in this sport you compete in but
most strength standards tables are like
hey a novice benches this much in
intermediate level lifter benches this
much in expert level lifter benches this
much just kind of assuming that how
strong you are is a pure uh function of
Simply how long you've been training
without really accounting for virtually
anything else including just how well
people respond to training like you you
could be
in expert level trainee who just
responds pretty poorly to resistance
training on average you put in you know
20 years under the bar uh you know what
you're doing you've you've gotten the
games that are available to you but
those games are just smaller than other
folks and it could be demoralizing to
look at a table like that and say oh
well you're you're a early intermediate
level deadlifter
um you've been a beginner for 13 years
congratulations yeah so I I think that
those are are generally unhelpful simply
because of the variability we see in
terms of how strong people get when
they're actually training pretty hard to
get strong so
uh again like within this one survey
within our audience with I will note a
biased sample like so I'm not saying
that this is how strong the average
person gets when after they've been
training for X period of time like these
are people who are training with the
express intent of trying to get as
strong as possible in squat bench and
deadlift so you know this probably won't
generalize to the typical gym you go to
unless you happen to train at a
powerlifting gym but just to give some
examples here after six to 12 months of
training the the typical male or like
the average uh one rep max squat
strength for a male lifter uh in this
survey was about 150 kilos which makes
sense
um you know from spending a lot of time
coaching power lifters training and
power lifting gyms if a new lifter comes
in and they they devote themselves to
lifting pretty hard you know three plate
Squad within a year like that's that's a
very realistic thing that that you see
all the time
um but yeah the the average was like 150
kilos which is 330 pounds but
the standard deviation was like 35 kilos
so when you go plus or minus two
standard deviations from the mean the
bottom end of that range is 176 pounds
about 80 kilos the top end of that range
is about 220 kilos or about 485 pounds
so you know we're not again even talking
about outliers here but some people
after six to 12 months like not to be a
hater they're still just not
particularly strong like if if you put
in a year under the bar and your one rep
max is still 175 like uh
you know you might be looking around at
your peers and say like man they it
seems like other people are gaining
strength faster than me is is there's
something wrong here and I would say
probably not I mean you're you're not an
outlier On The Low End uh you just have
a smaller than average response to
resistance training and on the top end
like yeah like I I know a handful of
people who've squatted close to 500 or
over 500 within their first year of
lifting
um and those folks are just very
fortunate but again we're not even
talking about outliers here like that's
like the 97.5 percentile uh similar
number similar numbers for women after
six to 12 months of lifting uh the
average squat was 90 kilos so that's
about 200 pounds uh but anything from 30
kilos or 66 pounds up to 150 kilos or
330 pounds were perfectly normal
responses again that's within two
standard deviations of the mean so like
just in terms of how strong people get
after training for comparable periods of
time there's huge huge variability here
and again just to reiterate I'm not
talking about outliers I'm talking about
plus or minus two standard deviations
from the mean which is where most people
fall and so if you're concerned like hey
I I seem to be experiencing smaller
strength gains than most people am I
atypical is something wrong probably not
like you probably fall within this sort
of range I'm talking about uh there
there's a very very good uh probability
that you do
so the next question here is is why why
do we see this amount of variability in
responses to training resistance
training aerobic training Etc
and
it's hard to say for for methodological
reasons but uh one of the contributors
almost assuredly is just genetics like
some people like they they just got a
better genetic draw for training than
other people did like if you look at
professional athletes in just about any
sport they pick better parents for for
their sport than you did and that's why
they're a pro and you're not
um but it's hard to say it's hard to put
a super precise estimate on exactly the
extent to which genetics per se uh
influence these things and this is
beyond the scope of this segment
um but I am somewhat skeptical of like
super precise estimates of heritability
um just because like
just because of like the methodology of
how those studies work and like I said
that's that's too big of a of a rabbit
hole to go down
um but like the the way that you would
typically try to estimate the
heritability of a particular trait is
you look to see uh when when people go
on the same sort of training
intervention how similar are responses
in people who are closely related so
parents and their children siblings
twins Etc compared to people who aren't
related so you know random person here
random person from some completely
different family you just kind of
aggregate that and look to see do people
who are related have responses to
training that are more similar than
people who aren't related on average and
if you see more similarity in family
clusters versus people outside of those
family clusters that that very strongly
suggests that there's a genetic
component
um and and that's what we see in all of
this stuff and like I said I I don't
like this is like we we talk about
sometimes on the podcast taking research
seriously versus literally I don't take
the precise heritability estimates
literally but I do think you can take
them seriously
um so there's very good evidence that
there is a genetic component to all of
this stuff but it's hard to say
precisely how large it is
um but I mean the genetic component is
there so one example is as of 2011 uh 22
specific genes had been discovered that
were uh strongly associated with a quote
strength power phenotype moving beyond
genetics uh other things certainly
matter as well uh you know determining
or being related to how well you'll
respond to training so you know are you
taking care of nutrition do you have
lifestyle factors that uh generally
promote gains in Fitness or generally
detract from them like are you sleeping
enough do you simply have enough time to
train uh is your life so stressful that
you can't recover particularly well all
of those things will certainly matter
um and then specifically for uh
hypertrophy there are a lot of little
things that we know to be predictive at
least in some circumstances of how well
people will respond to a hypertrophy
stimulus
uh and and citations for all of these
will be in the show notes but for
example satellite cell and myonuclei
responses seem to be predictive of uh
hypertrophy responses so people who have
larger elevations in Satellite cell
content and greater myonuclear accretion
following training tend to experience
more hypertrophy than those who don't
um particular micro RNA responses seem
to be predictive of training responses
that's from uh 2014 I believe study by
Davidson and colleagues uh ribosome
biogenesis seems to be predictive uh
which that one makes a lot of intuitive
sense if you think back to high school
biology ribosomes are the actual little
like cellular machines that build
proteins and so that's kind of like a
precondition for being able to build a
lot of additional new contractile
protein in your muscles so if two people
undergo go the same training stimulus
and one of them only has a small
elevation in ribosome content in their
muscles and one of them has a large
elevation in ribosome content of their
muscles who knows why those uh ribosome
responses differ but if they do the one
who winds up with more ribosomes will
just have more little cellular machines
that are capable of building those
proteins that their DNA is asking them
to build a particular myokine responses
seem to be predictive of gains in
hypertrophy and uh Androgen receptor
density although Androgen levels
themselves within the normal
physiological range might be associated
with hypertrophy but don't don't
actually seem to be all that predictive
but Androgen receptor density does seem
to be and those are just things we know
and there are probably half a dozen or
more additional things that are all
associated with how well you'll respond
to training that just simply haven't
been discovered yet
um
and also these aren't all independent
things like they are also probably
associated with your genetics and your
lifestyle so uh there are plenty of
things that can influence how well
someone will respond to training
um and and just one other thing I guess
to acknowledge here is at least when
we're talking about the research on
response variability to training one of
the things that needs to be acknowledged
is uh the potential impact of
measurement error or just day-to-day
biological fluctuations so you know if
um
let's say that you undergo a training
program and in real terms you put five
pounds on your bench over 10 weeks or
something like that so not a not a huge
gain in strength but you you did
increase strength like if you went to
the gym at the start of the program on
the absolute best conceivable day for
testing your bench press maybe you could
do 185 pounds and also under optimal
circumstances after the training program
you could do 190 pounds but you know
let's say during the the pre-testing
assessments things just weren't going
your way uh or no no it's the opposite
uh let's say during the pre-training uh
assessment everything was going your way
you felt great
um you know everything was just firing
right your strength was there and you do
hit 185 and it's a very good strength
test and then let's say 10 weeks later
you are like you're you're kind of true
unbiased like getting rid of day-to-day
fluctuations your actual strength has
gone up five pounds but let's just say
that on the day that the post training
assessment occurred it just wasn't your
day you had a shitty night of sleep the
night before uh like maybe your shoulder
feels tight for no apparent reason you
just slept on it funny uh your your
girlfriend or boyfriend just broke up
with you like you don't feel good when
you walk into the lab they test your
bench press strength and it's just not a
good day in the gym and you hit 180 so
you know the result from that study
would suggest your bench press strength
went down five pounds but in real terms
it actually went up five pounds and you
just had a bad a bad day of testing so
some of the variability we see in
responses to training are almost
assuredly due to stuff like that just
basic measurement error or day-to-day
fluctuations and strength or general
performance but like I want to make this
very clear the magnitude of different
responses we see between people are way
larger than could be attributed to just
technical measurement error or
day-to-day fluctuations and strength
like if if one person is experience of
experiencing a five kilo decrease in
squat strength and one person
experiences a 50 kilo increase in squat
strength those two people didn't
experience the same strength gains and
just had a good or bad day of testing
per year post like that's those are true
like very very quantifiable differences
between people but I I did just want to
make that note because uh you know when
you're talking about
any of this stuff like it's important to
keep stuff like measurement error or
just day-to-day fluctuations in mind but
those factors like that can account to
anywhere close to the sheer magnitude of
a variation we see